Building a performant
application
has everything to do
with understanding
how the hardware is working.
So you know the best
way is to work with it.
And at the core of
rendering performance
sits an easily misunderstood
hardware process
that governs how fast your
application can actually
render.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and if you're
looking to improve your
app's rendering performance,
you need to become familiar
with a term known as VSYNC.
But first, let's actually
take a step back.
Understanding VSYNC
starts with understanding
two other simple terms.
The first is refresh rate, and
it represents how many times
a screen can update
its display per second.
This value is specified
in hertz and is
constant based on the hardware.
The second term is
frame rate, which
measures how many times your GPU
can draw a frame per second--
for example, 30 frames per
second or 60 frames per second.
In this case, higher
is always better.
Now, refresh rate and
frame rate both need
to work together in order
to get your images drawn
to your screen.
The GPU will take in
your data, draw it,
and then the hardware will
push the output of that
to the screen.
This will happen over
and over and over again
during the lifetime
of your application.
But the problem is that
refresh rate and frame rate
aren't actually guaranteed to
occur at the same frequency.
Say if your frame
rate is actually
faster than your
refresh rate, then
you're going to be seeing
a few visual problems.
For example, imagine
taking a picture
and then rotating the
camera about five degrees
and taking another picture.
Now, cut that
second photo in half
and glue it on top
of the first one.
The two images would
be similar, but there'd
be a noticeable difference
between the top half
and the bottom half
along the cut seam.
This is known as
tearing, and this
is what occurs in
your application
if the frame rate and the
refresh rate are not lining up.
The issue is that your graphics
card uses one region of memory
to draw its frames into.
Each new frame will
overwrite the previous frame,
outputting data one line at
a time, starting at the top.
Now, when the screen
comes along to refresh,
it doesn't know what state
that buffer is actually in.
As such, it can grab a
frame from the GPU that's
not entirely
finished yet, meaning
it's got half of
the previous frame
and half of the current frame.
A solution to this is
known as double buffering.
Effectively, when the GPU is
done drawing a frame to memory,
known as the back
buffer, it will copy it
to a secondary area of memory
known as the frame buffer.
When it draws the
next frame, it'll
begin filling in the back buffer
while the frame buffer remains
untouched.
Now, when the screen
comes along to refresh,
it'll do so from the
frame buffer, which
isn't in the middle
of a draw operation.
This is where VSYNC comes in.
VSYNC, or vertical
synchronization,
will basically keep this copy
operation from back buffer
to frame buffer from
happening if the screen is
in the middle of
refreshing from it.
Having a frame rate higher
than a refresh rate is ideal,
since your GPU is refreshing
faster than your screen
is reading.
In this scenario, after a
successful screen refresh,
your GPU will be VSYNCed,
waiting for the next screen
refresh to occur.
In this scenario,
your frame rate
has been effectively capped
at your device refresh rate.
But what happens if your
screen is refreshing
twice as fast as
your GPU is drawing?
For example, the GPU is only
outputting 30 frames a second,
but the screen is actually
refreshing at 60 hertz.
This means that
every other refresh
will be sampling
from the same frame.
Or rather, the screen will be
displaying the same GPU frame
twice in a row.
When this happens
intermittently,
you get problems.
For example, if
your frame rate is
higher than refresh
rate but suddenly dips,
then the user will see a
smooth animation broke up
with sudden pauses,
followed by the rest
of the smooth animation.
This exact effect
manifests itself
to the user in a less than
smooth animated experience,
which is often described as jank
or hitching or lag or stutter.
And trust me, these
are the things
that you actually want to avoid.
Your application should strive
to remove these sudden dips
in frame rate by always
ensuring that your GPU gets
its data quickly
and has time to draw
the contents by the
next screen refresh.
But understanding VSYNC
is just the start.
Building a high-performance
application
requires you to
know what's going
on under the hood of
your Android device.
And to make sure that
you're doing that,
check out the rest
of the resources
on the Android
Performance Patterns page.
Oh, and don't forget to join
our Google+ community to start
building something amazing.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]